the numbers are staggering
border patrol sources estimating
criminal organizations took in at least
14 million dollars a day last month from
trafficking over the u.s mexican border
including
women children and families being
trafficked fox nation host larry logan
has covered the smuggling crisis at the
border and she joins us now
to react lara i think when we think of
cartels we think of drugs narcotics
narcotics smuggling what's increasingly
clear is that's only a portion of their
business
human smuggling and increasing piece of
the pie when it comes to their revenue
please tell us about us
well you're absolutely right will and
this has been going on for some time
but it's really become just a
multi-billion dollar business for the
cartels
and uh you know people still think of
them as the old drug trafficking
organizations
but they've expanded into so many other
things and they've become the most
powerful criminal organizations on earth
so what really most americans don't
understand is that when they see this
mass flow of people across the border
what they're looking at has been
described to me as the largest form of
modern slavery in the world
because and i've seen this with my own
eyes so many of the people coming across
will have a little card in their pocket
or a number written down which is a
routing number for a bank account for
the cartel if you haven't paid all of
your fees by the time you cross
they will collect and so many people
when you're in a restaurant in new york
and
you know you and your friends are
talking about oh isn't it wonderful how
these immigrants work
you know two jobs and they're so hard
working well guess what
they're working two jobs a lot of the
time because so much of their money is
going back to those cartels
who are still exploiting them and now
some of them are wearing wristbands
which link to databases and computers
so the cartel is able to track you
wherever you are and of course they can
also keep track of your family
you know on the other side of the border
so there's no escape for these people
and that's just a segment of the
population they'll help they're helping
to usher over the border
uh larry i know you've said this so i
want to follow up on it the southern
border is arguably the most valuable
stretch of ground
in the world tell me about that and the
fact that whether or not you are from
mexico or central america you might be
paying one rate but if you're coming
from china or the middle east you're
paying another rate
yeah well the cartels are extremely good
at exploiting
every single avenue to make as much
money as possible so they know that
if you're coming as a single adult male
it's much harder for you they can charge
more money
they know if you're coming from a
country like china the mexicans don't
want chinese
people there so when the u.s tries to
send them back no mexico is not taking
them
so china anyone with a nexus to
terrorism what
customs and border protection call
special interest aliens or sias you'll
hear that term
they can charge much higher numbers for
them and something else interesting that
we just learned was that in different
parts along the border there are now uh
charging different rates for example in
acuna which is just
across from del rio texas the rate is
lower than it is in
mcallen and rio grande valley and other
places so
but really what this indicates is that
the cartel can set whatever price they
want to
and uh you know when you have people
coming from haiti and countries like
that
they know that you're much more
desperate they know that it's much
harder for you and they charge you more
right all right larry i have less than a
minute but i want to ask you about the
press access at the border the body
administration is boxing out reports
boxing out reporters from seeing what's
going on we have quotes from
photographers who've been covering this
for years and through various
administrations saying it's never been
like this what's your reaction
well there's an extraordinary
photojournalist who has been covering
this for
four years for administrations and
he wrote an editorial in the washington
post john mua who said
you know that he'd never encountered
this before he was having to take
photographs from mexico using a long
lens
and uh this is you know what this is
really about is just hiding the
inescapable fact
that the biden administration is doing
what biden did when he was in the obama
administration and what the trump
administration did
which is uh that they have to at some
point hold people for processing
and when you hold women and children
whether it's behind bars or whether you
call it a cage or a chain link fence
or plastic pods as project veritas you
know released
yesterday in photographs that they
showed and congressman henry cuellar a
democrat
released in photographs from the border
it never looks good it plays on your
heartstrings
it's emotional i've been down there so
many times and my heart is broken for
these families
but it doesn't change the fact that
there is an extraordinary level of
hypocrisy
the biden administration doesn't want
this country to see the scale of this
crisis
they don't want to acknowledge it's a
crisis and they also don't want to
acknowledge that they're doing exactly
what donald trump did
using the same facilities the same
agents the same protocols
except with one very distinct difference
will is
that they are actually releasing a
number of people into the country
without even giving them a notice to
appear in immigration court
leaving it entirely up to those people
and that's bypassing the legal
immigration system
and it's made the border effectively
open and you know i have a colleague
from 60 minutes who's been waiting five
years
to hold his children he's here legally
his youngest daughter was six months old
when he left afghanistan
she's turning six in april six years old
he's been waiting
and that man has just been tortured by
this weight he loves his children more
than anything
and i don't hear anybody talking about
families have been separated in that way
by the legal immigration system what
happens to them now
all right lara logan has no agenda
return to the border is on fox nation
you get more analysis like
that which you just heard here on fox
and friends lara always good to talk to
you thank you
thank you will all right